[Musique]
avec vous là une phrase bonjour hélène
bonjour peut lire à la une de la presse
de ce mardi les difficultés d'abord des
négociations sur le nucléaire iranien
difficultés dont téhéran bruxelles et
washington se rendent mutuellement
responsables on a l'accord sur le
nucléaire iranien est il mort et enterré
raphaël bossi qui est le patron de l'
agence internationale de l'énergie
atomique aiea dont les gouverneurs sont
d'ailleurs réunis depuis hier à vienne
en autriche vient de demander une
nouvelle fois des explications à l'iran
sur la présence de traces d'uranium dans
trois sites non répertoriés après avoir
déclaré dans un premier temps ne pas
pouvoir garantir la nature exclusivement
pacifique du programme nucléaire iranien
la requête de raphaël go si on le voit
suscite évidemment la fureur de téhéran
et de gijon delhi accuse ce matin les
yeux à de s'être livré à une action non
constructive je cite qui aurait débouché
sur un résultat nous constructif
également l'accord sur le nucléaire
iranien de nouveaux points morts d'après
le journal libanais l'orient le jour la
république islamique exige la clôture de
l'enquète sur ses trois sites jugés
suspects mais aussi des garanties à plus
long terme en cas de changement
d'administration aux etats unis la
maison blanche de son côté jugé ces
demandes inacceptables
l'administration baden subissent en
outre à la fois la pression d'une
opposition intérieure qui est opposée à
cet accord et celle de son allié
israélien qui ne veut pas non plus en
entendre parler un accord sur le
nucléaire iranien dont les états unis se
sont retirés en 2018 c'était sous mandat
trump un accord qui serait aujourd'hui à
l'agonie elles le firent en veut pour
preuve la récente déclaration commune de
la france du royaume uni et de
l'allemagne qui fustige tous trois la
poursuite de l'escaladé nucléaire de
l'iran selon le journal les européens
auraient tracts et l'absence de réponse
de téhéran à leurs propositions et les
occidentaux s'interrogerait désormais
sur d'autres moyens je seek pour freiner
l'escaladé engagé par l'iran eux aussi
ils n s'interroge en russie on en
parlait dans le journal de groupe d'élus
municipaux ont demandé la démission de
vladimir poutine accusé entre autres
choses à voir je cite replonger le pays
dans l'ère de la guerre froide lorsque
times rapporte que des dizaines d'élus
de moscou et de saint-pétersbourg
également publié hier une lettre ouverte
demandant à vladimir poutine de partir à
l'appel à la démission qui seraient liés
à des allégations de fraude électorale
mais également alors ces massives on l'a
évoqué un des troubles ukrainienne selon
le washington post le recul de l'armée
russe en ukraine provoque aussi la
colère des propagandistes russe
propagandistes du kremlin le quotidien
américain fait état de débats parfois
houleux sur les plateaux de télévision
russes où des figures du nationalisme on
demandait vladimir poutine soin
d'appeler à la mobilisation générale
soit de quitter l'ukraine ou voire de
négocier un accord de paix avec kiev
sans transition en france le comité
consultatif national d'éthique doit
rendre aujourd'hui son avis sur la
nécessité ou non de légiférer sur l'aide
active à mourir d'après libération ce
comité devrait exprimer une opinion
dissidente c'est à dire sans consensus
entre ses membres emmanuel macron
devrait être annoncé dans la foulée la
mise en place d'une convention citoyenne
sur le sujet dès le mois prochain le but
étant de faire évoluer changer le cadre
légal d'ici la fin 2023 un moyen pour le
président de ne pas prendre parti sur un
sujet qu'il a longtemps tenté d'éviter
selon libération faut dire que le sujet
est très loin d'être consensuel le
journal chrétien lacroix s'interroge sur
l'opportunité d'une nouvelle loi et
rappelle qu'une texte qu'un texte qu'une
loi encadre déjà la fin de vie en france
1 c'est la loi claisse leonetti qui
avait été adoptée en 2016 la presse
française hélène qui rend hommage ce
matin à l'immense photographe américain
william klein disparu samedi dernier à
l'âge de 96 ans on appris sa disparition
hier seulement la disparition de ce
pionnier de les photographier de rue
fait la une en voie de libération qui a
choisi pour sa une cette photo
mondialement célèbre d'un gars
maintenant un revolver c'est une photo
qui avait été prise dans les rues de new
york en 1954 un cliché parmi les demies
lier d'autres dont le journal a
sélectionné quelques-uns des plus connus
notamment cette photo de serge
gainsbourg qui illustre la pochette de
l'un de ses albums où il apparaît les
yeux et les lèvres maquillées on ne se
quittent pas là dessus avant de vous
dira tout à l'heure pauline je tenais à
vous faire part d'une guerre passée sous
silence la guerre entre des habitants de
sydney et des cacatoès ces deux
canadiennes qui ont parlé ce matin ce
conflit aurait dégénéré en une véritable
course à l'armement selon des chercheurs
qui ont observé comment ces perroquets
qui sont très intelligents ont appris à
mieux manoeuvrer avec leur bec au fil du
temps pour ouvrir les couvercles des
poubelles et y récupérer évidemment de
quoi se nourrir là où ça se corse et que
et bien les habitants ne veulent pas de
ces vandales et ont à leur tour déployer
des trésors d'ingéniosité pour empêcher
les volatiles de mettre le bazar ans
comme ici avec cette technique dite de
la basket 1 c'est assez malin ou encore
et là c'est franchement sophistiqué
pauline avec des bouteilles d'eau
reliées par des fils elle ainsi que
c'est un système extrêmement complexe
qui montre évidemment à quel point
l'être humain sait s'adapter le cacatoès
visiblement aussi bien sûr merci
beaucoup et hélène on ne pouvait pas
effectivement se passer de cette
histoire à tout à l'heure dans paris